I want to talk to you about a math error
a math error to the tune of two trillion
dollars a lot of money here Donald Trump
is not exactly a details guy despite
what he said he throws idea out there
right ideas out there the details will
get figured out by I guess someone else
build the wall in Mexico will pay for it
well how who will who will get them to
pay for it how much will it cost
don't worry they're going to do it we're
going to shut down Muslim immigration
well with what legal mechanism how will
that work is it constitutional don't
worry it's all going to get figured out
when I'm president and one of the huge
crutches that Trump has used on the
economic side is to talk about how all
of his proposals will work out despite
being obviously ridiculous despite being
obviously deficit exploding because the
economy is going to do so well that
there's just going to be tons of extra
money to pay for everything and it turns
out that when it comes to Donald Trump's
budget Trump is counting that imaginary
expected economic growth two trillion
dollars worth of it two times that's
right Donald Trump has a two trillion
dollar error in his budget Trump has
made the claim that the budget he
proposed over a decade will balance okay
and then he's going to be able to
balance the budget without cutting
defense and without cutting retirement
spending how is that possible because
there's going to be two trillion dollars
in revenue from future economic growth
totally unbelievable totally vague but
okay it's what Trump claims the problem
is that the hugely deficit exploding
nature of Trump
tax cut program which mostly benefits
the rich is going to also be paid for by
the same two trillion dollars in revenue
from future economic growth Trump is
counting the two trillion dollars in
future growth that is hard to believe
even will exist two times this is not
exactly forgetting to round up the
restaurant tip 2 the next dollar imagine
an equivalent conversation with your
significant other listen I know we're
stretched thin but I figured out a way
to get a car lease that's an extra 100
bucks a month I'm going to spend $100
more on my car lease but I'm going to
cut $100 a month from my monthly going
out with my friends expenses up
okay a hundred up a hundred down makes
sense and then the next day you go back
to your significant other and you say
hey I'm going to increase the cost of my
spending on video games by a hundred
dollars a month but I'm going to pay for
it
by cutting a hundred dollars from my
monthly going out with my friends
expenses wait wait wait
so you're going to cut $200 from going
out to pay for both things no I'm going
to cut the same hundred dollars both
times
to cover the increase of two hundred
dollars doesn't make sense and here's
how the White House attempted to explain
this away and it is just gold so I'm
aware of that the criticisms and I would
simply come back and say look there's
other places where we were probably
overly conservative in our accounting we
stand by the numbers now we thought that
the assumption that the tax reform would
be deficit-neutral was the most
reasonable of the three options that we
had sure we could either assume that our
tax reform was deficit neutral we could
assume it would reduce the deficit we
would assume it would add to the deficit
and given the fact that were this early
in the process about dealing with tax
reform we thought that assuming that
middle road was the best way to do it
you can you imagine a more bogus
response it's like multiple conflicting
responses we've we've been wrong about
other things too so that makes up for
the double counting of two trillion
dollars in revenue that would appear out
of thin air that were early in the
process of anyway and then at the core
is that even counting the two trillion
once is nuts right don't think for a
second that if they only count this two
trillion dollars one time that then it
all makes sense
it was never coherent when they were
counting the two trillion one time it's
doubly incoherent when you're counting
the same two trillion dollars twice and
two trillion dollars just sounds like so
much money that is kind of hard to wrap
your head around it yeah it is very
significant I mean the entire
discretionary budget for one year is a
little over one trillion dollar absolute
so this adds up to about two years and
that's all of defense spending that's
the Department of Education and and
every veteran spent it so it's a lot
yeah so there are two options here it's
either an embarrassing mistake or it's
deliberate deception and neither is
respectable and neither inspires
confidence not to mention by the way
that economists agree that tax cuts for
the rich aren't actually good for the
economy we don't have evidence that that
the standards are voodoo
to trickle-down economic stuff actually
work that's at the base of it layer two
of the pyramid is counting the two
trillion once doesn't make any sense and
the cherry on top right the tip of the
pyramid is when you count the imaginary
two trillion twice it really really
really doesn't make sense yeah this is
obviously going to be a deficit funded
tax cut and this is coming from the guy
in Donald Trump who promised to
eliminate the national debt in eight
years not the deficit the debt well
hopefully he won't get eight years to
try to do it and obviously fail
miserably a lot of discussions about
this on our reddit discussion forum join
us there david pakman.com slash reddit
today's program is made possible in part
by Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s